[Music]
hello we're at the 2019 girl from
technology conference I'm Silvia Haas
and I run Wolfram's social media so I'm
here with my co-host I'm Kathy Ponte and
I was at this year's wolfram summer camp
and this is the Vander Kapadia and he's
the manager of calculus and algebra and
today he's going to be talking to us
about the interactive linear algebra
course on Wolff you okay thank you
Ruthie and Sylvia it's great to be here
I'm going to talk about a topic which
has been I've been kind of obsessed with
the last year that's linear algebra and
you might wonder what's a MOOC well a
MOOC stands for massive open online
course it's massive so we can have 8,000
people listening to a particular lecture
it's open anyone can be there you don't
have to be a particular age be in a
particular country or study at a
particular school and it's online well
because that's where we put all our
lectures and vote from you and it's just
like a college course or high school
course but it's much more friendly and
much more geared towards people who want
to learn at their own pace so that's the
my topic for today's so is that what
you've been working on like as your day
to day job my there's my day to day job
my day job almost is a manage of
calculus and algebra so we have a
probably eight nine people in our team
would do different things so I'm
basically a calculus person to start
with so differential equations and then
what we call asymptotics and all
construction give a talk at the
conference on calculus algebra another
one asymptotics but this over here is a
kind of follow up from something which I
did last year which was an interactive
calculus course last year we released an
introduction to calculus MOOC and that's
me successful in the sense that we get
roughly 8,000 people coming to a website
every month and I've reached
as far as remote Nigeria and I had a
student write to me saying that you know
he didn't have Mathematica didn't have a
computer somehow borrowed one did the
course so I thought that we are not
touching lives not just educating so I
thought that we should now do a linear
drum move so what is linear algebra it's
something that you might have studied at
middle school high school things like
you know solving system of equations etc
and this really is an interrupt because
of I'm not trying to assume anything
from anyone it's meant for I would say
high schoolers should do just fine on
this course it starts with a very basic
and picks you all the way up to very
modern stuff like data science and image
compression in the kind of see on your
iPhone so I've put in a lot of effort in
listen to my day job which is calculus
development this is what I've been doing
in the afternoons and evenings all of
last year awesome
so can you walk us through a little bit
more about the question of course so the
the core of this course is 25 video
lessons you know I think that many
course at high school college are kind
of long and it's okay if you're a
classroom but you're going to think on
your own you do want 20 files the limit
I set myself so the course begins with
what's the linear algebra which is what
you see over here talks a bit about the
history of the subject how it began why
some parts are very difficult why some
parts are easy why you don't do linear
algebra who didn't matter when it would
if you want to economics engineering
data science computer science in today's
world you better know linear they gonna
ask you how good you linear we apply to
grad school really good grad school they
ask you how good is the computer
programming how to put them in algebra
on the other hand all you need to know
for this particular course is just some
algebra and trigonometry so if you know
that sine of 30 degrees is 1/2 that's
good enough if you don't I tell you so
this is a very friendly kind of course
I've put in wrong effort to make sure
that nothing goes out ten minutes which
is about what people can focus on in
typical online lesson and the nice thing
that we got the Wolfram cloud and what
the Wolfram cloud does let you try
things on your own interactively so you
could you know you you might do draw a
three by three matrix on your own but if
you were from cloud you could try a 500
by 500 calculation to come back in a
second or less and so the nice thing is
that everything's available to you
computation explanation exercises and
they're so good as I don't much like
eggs and I mean I wish that there were
more exams in the world but the fact is
there are so there's just a few quizzes
to make sure that you understand what
you're doing but everything's nice and
friendly this is an easy course it's not
a typical College in the algebra course
this one here do someone who wants to
learn linear algebra and launch the
career and data science or wherever they
want to go so just a bit more maybe
about course and that's a you know I
think that many parts of math myself
it's dry you take high school geometry
I've taught high school already many
other it's kind of you wonder why would
he know what to do this well I wouldn't
wonder but most people would you know so
in the course of try to give some nice
applications of linear which is what
made the subject so interesting like you
know economic models when you go to the
University in study economics you might
have a system of five hundred equation
finite long then around 1940 that
actually happened a Nobel prize-winner
yontiff was trying to solve a fine fine
system it took him I think fifty six
hours to do the calculation and a few
months of program it today can do that
about 0.1 seconds in the cloud so I
invited try that in the course last week
there's a lot of publicity about
something called quantum supremacy and
that space is being called quantum
entangled move it goes back to Albert
Einstein around 35 so I'll try to give
an idea how you do quantum entanglement
using linear algebra and would see over
years me playing at the bottom of the
screen is me playing the table which is
an Indian drum and I try and show that
if you allow yourself just a bit of
compression you can
pretty good compression of that image to
suit your needs so this is some you know
all the time not ask but your iPhone
your computer doing it all the time
it's good to know how to do it and
linear algebra is the place to learn it
and maybe just one last thing now that
I've spoken about all that is that you
know when you do something nice you put
it all there for you but maybe tend to
allows on the videos you surely want us
to do something for you and tell you you
did well you know so we will give you
nice free certificate if you finish off
course and you can probably say I know
linear algebra which is which is a big
achievement in this today's world so
that roughly is how I see this coin so
you said there would be a few quizzes so
when you open the course what are the
resources that are available to you like
lectures or videos are right so the
video lessons will kind of pour off the
course you you can learn a topic and
then you can do some practice exercises
which are similar to what was on the
class and then after a few lessons
you'll have a quiz the quiz multiple
choice not very difficult at all but the
point is you can always go back and
forth and look at the video look at the
exercise and if people want we can
certainly give more but I've tried to
keep everything down to five questions
so you know you don't take too much time
on them but believe me if someone didn't
know linear algebra a month later they
would if they followed high scores so
what are you future plans for this
project well the things that we have
been I am portable from you which has a
mission of trying to educate people to
nacio stephen wolfram teachers middle
school students every Sunday and build
and he's actually much into educating
people he wants us to try and give lots
of different courses not just canceled
ineligible maybe high school algebra
could be other things
differential equations we have plans we
want to help people do the AP courses
all over the country
so we have plenty of plan but honestly
what I'm looking for is people like you
should be or Sylvia who want to learn
mathematics and tell us what do you
think might be a good thing faster to do
so that's in terms of future future
plans yes so I think good from you is uh
it's a massive resource by my reckoning
we probably get more than a hundred
thousand people in someone's coming
website because it's got hundreds of
videos for all kind of thing you wanna
learn data science you wanna learn image
processing on calculus linear algebra
whatever it's all involve from you it's
completely free and you can just learn
it so this particular course by the way
is about to be kind of shipped it's
almost ready a couple of months worth of
work left over here the website needs to
go up I'm done so basically over the
last few months I've been recording at a
hectic pace and I have handed over
charge but very soon in a couple of
months
everyone convertible for me the
government website and just learn do you
have anything else to share with us well
what I would like to see I just wanna
take it back a little bit to an earlier
slide and you know many do mathematics
the question is why something's easy
invited something is hard and the reason
is that it depends on when he came up in
history and also you know like you see
where you're Gabriel Cramer who was
around 750 and people cream actually one
with the long hair he actually studied
determinants and he was one of the
pioneers of linear algebra and then
later on conference browse cows towards
worldly squares which used child prodigy
and then much later mill fifty later
Kaylee and Sylvester who actually in
London and those days could not make a
living doing
cymatics oh they were lawyers and actual
scientists that kind of stuff so and
then much later this rate became more
abstract so what I'm trying to say that
many many study mathematics you wonder
why is something so hard that's because
it took a long time for people
discovered so if you find it hard so the
people discovered it so I've tried to
follow the historical process of
learning linear algebra and I hope that
you enjoyed thank you so much for coming
in to talk with us once again this was
Devinder Kapadia and make sure to check
out his linear algebra course on welcome
you thank you very much
[Music]